well mass confusion no doubt that was
quite the discussion today and
all weekend the cdc recently announced
those are
those who are fully vaccinated now have
the option to not
wear a mask some businesses not ready
though to have you remove them
some others are while others like target
walmart and even costco following the
cdc guidelines
sally jaramillo joins us live from
henderson where she found some
not sure what to do and some restaurant
owners who are relying
on an honor system sally
kirsten many restaurant owners tell me
they are trusting those
who are wishing to come in and dine in
here at gaetano's wrist starante on
easter near saint rose parkway those who
are vaccinated have taken off their
masks
and some still keeping it on owner
nicholas palmieri says they have gone
above and beyond to make sure employees
and guests are safe
making sure to follow all regulations
from the health district and cdc
we all know dining is popular here in
las vegas so with the new mass
guidelines this past weekend was
definitely a test
of what people are comfortable with
plumberry says some guests still wore
masks others had them off and he hopes
they're being safe
for example our employees who are
vaccinated
they do not have to wear a mask majority
of my employees have been with me
for seven plus years and
they're like family
rodrigo ibarra vice president of don
tortaco says they're still unsure the
best protocol to take
and following what other restaurants are
doing relying on an
honor system some other confusion has
been at grocery stores and other
retailers especially since clark county
is still requiring mass
i reached out to brian wachter from the
retail association of nevada
brian rachter says kobe 19 guidelines
should follow the science and it's time
to move away from mass
with vaccines reducing transmission
rates